I'm I I was gonna say am I allowed to
use this because I kept making jokes the
whole time during the PlayStation
conference that everyone looked like
they were rendered and what I assume
happen is that that because they were
all shooting in remote locations they
tried to balance everything the same way
so everyone looks like there until dawn
like a bunch of hos process right yeah
yeah I was watching you know I was
watching and with a bunch of developers
and yeah exactly the same thing of like
like like actual 3d artists going
I don't know that cloth I don't imagine
you know anything about you that video
process but for reference for everyone
who doesn't know Austin showed up in the
conference yesterday I did not know he
was gonna be there I just went Austin
wait at what point ok literally in the
conference he's like big big face you
said something about the future yeah it
was so funny got into a clip of that by
the way yeah it was just a funny like
they're so they they had Matt Nava
record some stuff for it because
pathless was was folded into the the
montage of stuff at the end and so Matt
had done some special capture of the
current state of the game based for for
that purpose and they said you know will
you we kind of answer some of these
questions on camera and we'll figure out
how to fit it in and they said and then
I just get a message saying hey Austin
you should do this too but we need it
tomorrow or kind of thing and so yeah I
just grabbed my I grabbed my phone and
just did it in here this was I like
maybe a week ago I had no idea I had
kind of forgotten about what it was for
because it's like a week ago
feels like obviously something 400 years
ago our world and the industry yeah so
many pearls of wisdom the funny thing
was that you know they said they asked
me to specifically speak about you know
excitement for tech and blah blah blah
and polygons and yeah I mean it's it's
not unlike what happened here
you know where it's like the clip us
quoting a press release basically as if
as if we have this
hot you know hot breaking news scoop
that were were unleashing but so yeah I
think because what they quoted me as
saying was if I if I if I am so bold it
was horrendously cliche because I
basically in the context of a
five-minute video I sent them you know
talking about various tech or whatever
the moment where I say expect the
unexpected is the part that they grab
and did you I had that I didn't even
remember saying that I was like that
it's that's awfully platitude ish for
for me III like to think that I do hope
my wish is
I trust that that's a word is that a
platitude ish well platitude is the word
oh I understand I know the the the I'm
talking about your derivative I'll go
with I'll go with it was rather
platitudinous there we go that that's
more believable I love because I think
ps4 we didn't they did a similar thing
like with bunch of talking heads and
they actually like because back then we
could you know travel and do things they
liked I went to a studio and they
recorded man yeah like similarly like
did like five minutes like yeah it's
really interesting how this technology
is going to do this and this is probably
the future and then it's probably the
future was like the one Xbox I've done I
did a Nintendo one and every single time
I'll give a candid answer and they'll be
like we need just like a little bit like
fine like they really need you to say
the the dramatic emotional phaser gets
cut yeah that's how it works it's true
you're about to say something I was
making a terrible joke I said was David
Byrne a part of that hey two of the
squares three of the squares alright
welcome to another episode of play watch
listen everybody I am watch I listen
what am i which one of my weight
recently
though serious case of launch week wait
your launch week brain I'm saying you've
got launch week what's what am i which
we are my you are watch no you're all
three Troy you can be all three guys you
have me in the throes of an existential
crisis these are the questions you can
watch listen to your voice and you can
watch you do things so you are face all
three I might show up talk about who
else showed up at the conference I made
I made a few appearances can I do my
intro first before you brag about your
PlayStation Boston wintery he was a
video game composer now I'll most famous
friend because he was the only one who
showed up in the PlayStation Conference
Troy Baker Troy probably it she's gonna
point out so I think may have actually
shown up much earlier as you definitely
showed up his Joel did you show up as
anyone else
I was the pre-roll yeah I showed up
there were there were multiple
iterations of characters I've done Joel
was in there Higgs was in there Delsin
was in there Sam Drake was in there but
what I loved is that they they used the
young Sam
Austin chase Austin who played young
Austin is like who plays that
character's name is like we were born
for greatness so I was like oh when they
said that I got chills there's a lot of
things that I have mixed feelings about
the about the conference but will that
we our episode and then we also have
game director Mike Bethel who did not
show up in the conference Italy utterly
uninvolved to me you're pointing it
nobody I guess it would sort of be
Austin not appointing you know this is
here for me Austin and there's there's
you wait God dang it
there's it happens based on the timing
of who joins so usually Austin joins
first he was notably lost today so it
usually is the exact same for
but it changes every time so wait your
top left I'm top right I'm top right I
just want to know where I stand guys I
want to know it's funny we if we did
this like a book in mind it actually is
perfectly the a atm
actually all right this is great content
for our largely audio listening podcast
imagination people lotta empathy for the
crowd all right so we saw the the
PlayStation Conference first first
question how do you guys feel about the
way it looks people have a lot of hot
takes on this the big hero six model yep
that Playstation 5 it looks to me like a
router I know a lot of people say that
please like what does it look like what
does it look like like what does it look
like be cute be cute I know what he's
fishing for I want you to say it to what
did I say it look like you said they're
like a router oh you bastard
[Laughter]
a root sir I okay are you let's get an
analysis are you a lay flat or stand up
Piatt playstation guy her per person
okay
so my entire home console setup will not
work if things have to stand I have one
Xbox that I have standing in the only
place that works but my home console
like the cabinet I don't think is tall
enough to house the next generation of
consoles they have to lay sideways so
doesn't I've seen pictures of it yes but
they never showed it is the idea an
article tomorrow Biffle confirmed yes
but also the curviness of it and its
ears and everything they want
caddywhompus it shouldn't be it should
just stay on the lips which in theory is
better for ventilation Troy
[Laughter]
I don't I yield my remaining time to the
floor they look like lips besides I
don't know what else you want me to say
I was gonna say I loved Troy's like I'm
11 years old
great sex ed class reaction just there
was really wouldn't touch anything on
the bottom which means it'd be better
better ventilated and what the reports
coming out I keep saying is PlayStation
4
sorry PlayStation 5 is going to have
better load times but the Xbox series X
should have more consistent frame rates
like it's like they're targeting
different things it's been so
interesting to watch them openly compete
with each other even in interviews like
Phil's been really open about how he
doesn't think the Xbox Series X is going
to sell well which it's all just been
such a bizarre launch period and this
conference is like a very good example
of like you were saying Mike wanting it
to be e3 but knowing it's not because
everyone looks like they're a [ __ ]
robot for some reason it was so strange
to watch
I was extensive mocap for my cameo it
made me real I was watching it and then
I got super sad because it reminded me
that I'm normally there and we're
normally sweating our balls off outside
first and everyone's getting too drunk
before and we all pile in recess yeah
with the food trucks and we go to the
conference it's it's a nightmare to get
down to the forum or where is it that
Austin LA alive you mean it's a big call
Paul Cameron yeah it's a UCLA it said at
UCLA it's is that the forum no it's at
the floor
whatever it's that doesn't by the
Convention Center so it's all there and
we're all you know it's like at this
great little you know mixer beforehand
but it's outside and so everyone's hot
and we all go inside and then it's just
like we're surrounded by our colleagues
and just this
voracious crowd of people that's so
excited to see this stuff and it's dark
and it just reminded me of the fact that
we're not there
and without that haptic feedback of the
second that you see the logo come up and
people like we knew it we knew they were
working on something and you hear the
crowd gasp that a lot to me is what I
miss we also missed that even from
people who don't have the privilege that
we do of being able to attend e3 and
posts in which I do love it is my
favorite watching it they usually have
crowd sounds so not even having that
does mean the atmosphere is really odd
and I feel like maybe this this
presentation and I don't know if it's
because if the way it was laid out of
the way it was paced didn't grab me in
the way that III press conferences
usually do like I wasn't like glued to
my screen maybe with the exception of
spider-man that was the one time very
early on that I was like oh my god yes
even just the intro of that like Yuri's
voice coming over the top and then just
watching that suit evaporate and repeat
that was a great reveal for my really
gross because it pans slowly and then
you see his mask and I love that it's
also a man and somebody Ike's working on
like III think that from what I can tell
that that Spider Man I think it's
literally cold Spider Man Miles Morales
is going to be like a standalone like a
lost legacy or a Left Behind was for the
loss of us rather than she clarified
that they could make a million of those
than I will take them forever
spider-man performing keep doing that I
I texted Ned Luke and I said I was like
it just doesn't get old it's like a
great old leather jacket it looks so
good and I can't help but slip into it
when I saw the GTA 5 I was like all over
me just just I want I want to jump back
into that world it looked great
I want more story content on what more
heists I have no idea what they're
offering but everything that they showed
I was like and to my knowledge maybe
some of us can can can confirm or deny
this
that's the first title that's done to
console jumps right can you think of
another one that's that's because that
came out on past gen it did then was one
of the first to port to new gen and
it'll be also next gen Xbox backwards
compatible makes that complicated he
made a bad joke it's like is that a joke
heartbreaking a little bit he's dead on
the inside I'm sure there's gonna be
more right compatibility program makes
that monkey right ports I mean they have
a dedicated team up in Seattle who work
on that they do put a lot of effort into
making sure those original Xbox games
can play an icebox one but that's not
quite the same they still haven't been
able to do
I mean modern warfare 2 they've all in
the campaign so we'll leave that one
alone but I'm talking about like
remasters that that's not a porn that's
not backwards compatibility that is a
like we up rezzed
everything like even when they showed it
was like dang dude those character
models look fantastic the world looks
great that there was nothing but besides
that I guess the the Resident Evil was
looked the best to me but I don't know
if that's necessarily indicative of the
game but I was just kind of underwhelmed
and this sounds shitty by the way this
is the problem is that for for me and
then I feel like I'm dominating right
now but it's the launch of a new
consults the launch of here here this is
what is the shining example of this new
generation of consoles and the best of
the best of the hardware and so I feel
like the expectation is always so high
any game that gets made is amazing but
loop a death loop looked really cool to
me III thought that there was more I was
more impressed by the diversity of
narrative I mean those two games that
are very similar I love them so much I'm
talking about there were more and I knew
this was gonna happen
um years ago because we saw this the
shift happening we saw it first with the
Last of Us we saw with horizon new dawn
we saw it even with infamous the
standalone DLC for that first light with
them shifting over and going it's fun to
play as a female character and and not
just like ticking the box but also like
no we're writing and creating female
characters
not since Samus has there been like a
strong female protagonist that is like
an iconic character for a console
generation right and if you look at the
lineup of Sony of PlayStation it's
pretty balanced now because horizon new
dawn you've got these these great
characters and and being able to see
people of color and females strong
female characters that were at the root
of the game not that's not the cable
reader that the anyway the route of the
game the routes of the case yes I but
III just I didn't I didn't see anything
that was like I guess the moon moon baby
there like them the that last one in
terms of things that technically
impressed me gran turismo of course that
was a game that they always show some
racing games show off new hardware it
did look stunning but I was actually
also really impressed by ratchet Clank
that gameplay was like the way that it
seems to actually pull dimensions into
one another and the I'm jumping to
conclusions here but it seemed to me
like that game in order to run would
have sort of multiple dimensions
immediately loading in for you to be
able to pull from them because different
people can do it at different times and
I actually think that is technically
incredibly impressive and very next-gen
like I don't know that we could do that
on the hard way that we have today that
was the one that I was like it's a
sleepy game because it looks childish
people on I'm gonna register what that
game is doing but that one I was like
that's [ __ ] nuts if that works the
way that I think it does shout-out to
Russia it does I love it that's the one
that's like the secret kind of killer
app I think that's the one you always
have the game that shows off the new
feature but
we're so used to the new innovative
feature being something completely
gimmicky in terms of like that you know
the touchpad on the top of the the ps4
controller or like something like that
no that's that's 100% just built as a
game to show off relatively fast loading
it's not instant and that actually makes
me more impressed and makes me believe
that it's actually kind of indicative of
the real game yeah because there's
actually a hidden load when you're
transitioning through a portal there's
about two seconds well about one one to
two seconds where they basically put
like a texture map on it there's not
like portal where you just walk straight
through there's a there's a slight load
blaze like where you go out into a
universe so it is loading and they faked
the transition basically like it's yeah
it's like a two-second elevator ride in
Mass Effect but that's fine that's
that's no one's expecting instantaneous
absolutely instantaneous but that's kind
of hiding that stutter nicely and yeah
kind of game the wooden it's like I felt
the same way cuz I was like I don't know
if I'm just perceiving something that's
not actually there but I really think
that like Ratchet and Clank is the one
that that is the hardware one that I'm
like want to know more about that's the
interpretation again isn't so many I
feel like tell me how this works because
from my understanding you have however
many universes you have in this game
will have them any Maps and you are
letting me transition between them that
fast whenever I want to I imagine
there's some restrictions on that but
that that is very very very impressive
if they've managed to do that that
quickly like that's the one that that's
very undo right now everything also
concise like you could you could fake it
you could do like smaller environments
and overlap them and there's been games
that have done that kind of jumping
between dimensions kind of thing before
but the scale of world like it's a very
good it's a very good first game of a
new generation it's like just touching
on that just testing that water the one
I think as well is going to surprise
people a Spider Man in the same way is
that's very quietly an obvious little
and he seems obvious to me that that's
basically the test case of the loading
for um open-world games so they're
basically going to port over New York
presumably they'll have to
false Travel will be instantaneous or
it'll like in the demos we've seen where
although that's ironic
fade to black fade back up in your way
you are and you're not there anymore
loading times it's funny I don't know
and I think will surprise people I don't
know I don't know a single game a single
open-world game that has the most
underused fast travel yeah exactly I
don't think I've ever once deliberately
thought like it wasn't even that I
didn't use it I remember thinking
consciously why on earth would I do this
like they finally managed to crack the
code of a satisfying spider-man
simulator and it was so much so that
like when I get a mission and it pings
across Manhattan like I mean I'm in yeah
exactly I'm like in the Bronx and and
the missions in Battery Park I'm going
oh hell yeah I have like five minutes of
swingin before reacting to being
spider-man the first time in that game
oh yeah yeah it's really good so Brian
is in the creative director I believe
it's his role on that game he shared
this video on his Twitter I'll link it
to you guys of this little boy reacting
to swinging through the city for the
first time and his face is just the
cutest thing you've ever seen and I
replied to his tweet and I was like I
think I did the same thing didn't tell
Brian the context of I did the same
thing while sitting next to Brian 100% I
played that game he was sitting next to
me and I remember my face being like oh
my god and there are games that have
touched on that like I love prototype
does a really good job
Saints Row does a really good job Troy's
Saints Row as we call it in this house
does a really good job of like making
just getting across the city really
really fun but yet the fluidity of
spider-man is crazy and I think that's
actually a really good one to to use as
a barometer for comparison if you play
model spider-man and then you play
spider-man Miles Morales in quick
succession from one another the
difference between those two probably is
going to be really telling where the
hardware is concerned obviously it's
year one things change dramatically but
I feel like that is a really good one
too
like it is the same engine it will be
the same assets but it is actually going
to be a tested performance like maybe
how combos can get crazy I don't know
like that that is a really good one to
point out that way and I think like I
enjoyed the conference but I think I'm
I'm largely like a little bit with you
true where I was a little underwhelmed
in a lot of those games had already been
announced a lot of them but a lot of
them hadn't it's true and again I I feel
like it's so easy to go yeah it wasn't
up to my standards it's it's I I'd if
anyone listing in the industry feels
like I'm being disparaging in any way of
what is clearly years and years and
years of work and has nothing to do with
the game it has everything to do with I
think just the context of this show
coming out and how I felt about it
right so it's it's it even was
indicative of what we're going through
right now the whole time was a reminder
of the situation that we're in which
she's brutal and totally not that fault
I actually think considering the
circumstances it looked very
professional I feel like they did a very
good job considering how difficult it
sounds like that production was with
them trying to do it and not doing it
most industry professional problem
solvers man that it is if they have
constantly proven themselves and I I
will just kind of sit and watch her mand
kind of talk about anything because
there's there's there's just this part
of me that feels like at any moment he's
going to turn into a Bond villain I'm
kind of waiting for that to happen but
he's just the nicest guy and I get this
like I love Jack Trenton you know III
felt like Playstation it fills I feel
like I'm removing him I love when I hear
the people there at the Helms of these
consoles truly speaking passionately
about it's like we're everything is
always like we're giving the player more
power there's a power to the players has
always been Playstations thing and I
feel like clearly these are these are
companies that have to meet quarterly
reports and and if they don't pay their
bills they don't get to make games but I
still feel at the root of
is the fact that they really do want to
make experience or players that are
constantly blowing people away and if
they don't I don't feel clearly they
don't get there until they're blown away
so that I think I think that point is
lost a lot because the companies of that
size are always having to have you know
or earning supports and those kinds of
like shareholder meetings and that kind
of thing because yeah I've never once
been in a meeting on a project big or
small where the meeting is I think this
will sell more copies if we do this it
is always how how great does this make
the jump field this person just
implemented a new feature that that
tweaked the animations and like just hit
jump how exciting is it to jump or like
look how beautiful this textures we just
got new backgrounds in or what it's
always there's always is it almost like
childlike excitement to it even an even
in its most you know I'm always guilty
of being kind of idealistic and and
perhaps naive about these kinds of
things and I tend to see the best to the
point of almost willful ignorance
sometimes and and and you know so I
recognize that I may be overly Rosalie
painting some of these things but to me
it is always what you're trying to say
and to that end I actually do disagree
well I shouldn't say disagree I just had
a very different reaction to it than the
two of you Troy and Alana because I I
don't know if it's precisely because of
just how worn down I've been feeling and
kind of exhausted by just the the
cumulative this is Troy and I were
talking earlier about the cumulative
effect of of starting you know months
ago with with the beginnings of
quarantine and lockdown and it's just
like this continuous escalation of
things feeling more demanding
emotionally and more exhaustively kind
of
large-scale it's like the problems are
just are always seemingly getting more
intense and the desire to try to
positively contribute in some way is
always kind of pulling harder and harder
and harder and at some point it's just
so exhausting and so I think the result
of which was that I was I think I went
into it really prepare to feel like a
kid who's just wowed by all this magic
being wheeled out for me I think I I
think there was a part of me that
desperately needed to to revert to a
kind of innocent just just mouth dropped
kind of excited because I felt like I
definitely had moments I felt like that
after every trailer I mean every single
one of them I was like oh my god I gotta
get that and I was like messaging yawn
at that gorilla going holy [ __ ] horizon
like this me like one after the race now
is it the wolf I was like my little kid
excitement of the most but that game had
already that was really nice this is so
cool what I'm so interested in what it
is it just looks so sweet one of the
people who was on our live stream said
this is what I think I look like when
I'm playing Dark Souls like it's a very
dark souls ii thing but this is what I
feel like I look like when I'm playing
dog souls so just like this wheaty of
wide-eyed kind of idiot
running around in this really cool wall
like I was very unboard with that
still thinking about bug snacks but
Austin is there anything like in
particular that that really blew you
away um I I don't know honestly it's
hard for me too it's hard for me to
single any one particular out simply
because I found myself just like on this
roller coaster saying like that could
that could that that looks amazing and
that look that looks amazing and just
kind of one after the next and and
feeling like the a lot of them seem to
really throw down bold sort of design a
narrative where I
to my like I had a there were a handful
where I thought I don't really know what
that game is and but not in a way where
you know like because obviously there's
a continuous tension always of you know
show us a gameplay trailer like this is
too deceptive of the game people have
gotten wise to the idea that these
cinematic trailers can be very can be
very very misleading and and but there
were some like like Troy was saying the
moon baby III can't remember that where
a war was but that was one where I was
watching it and I fish kind of
transfixed going I I'm if the game is
anything at all like what I'm seeing I
don't I don't know that I've played
something like quite like this though
yeah like a really cool scene it was
like oh he jumped off the planet and
landed on the moon surreal yeah I just
it just immediately looked Japanese to
me like that game definitely hologram
does it look like ghost like like ghost
cats I thought it was a hologram because
you also like see its ribs and stuff
like it's a glitching hologram but then
there was also stray the one with the
robots what you play is the cat which I
was full cyberpunk with yeah yeah also
everyone messaged me assuming it was my
game a very Basilian game like the first
like minute of that trailer my country's
been out like yeah I think yeah but it
but it does kind of definitely like the
robots and there's some stuff that looks
like similar to our games I smell it
from a mile off he made that but I feel
no I didn't but like I did guy could get
ya a few people messaging this often but
it totally looks beautiful looks much
better than something I'd make so I'm
super into that one that looks amazing
I've no idea what it is
I see a play as the cats I love yeah
that's the thing I to me it was just one
one one very promising you know who
knows how many of those will turn out
be really great obviously to Troy's
point a minute ago there's untold
hundreds or thousands of people working
very hard to try to make every one of
those games really really great I
thought that the presentation did
everybody a favor like there was no game
sometimes when you have a lineup like
that there's one or two that kind of
somehow end up being like the the kind
of forgotten stepchild what it feels
like they're they're sort of like aren't
you cute amongst all these titans and I
didn't feel like anything that way I
think they balanced it really well and
there was a good mix of games that look
more family-friendly and colorful and
cute and Indies oh yeah the more serious
games I felt like the variety of games
shown was like probably the biggest
strength it was really impressed by that
and to your point there are things that
I hadn't seen before even stylistically
I feel like ghost Wyatt Tokyo I think
it's cool goes wow yeah that from what
we've seen of it before looks like a
horror game but then it turns out it's a
horror game where you're basically a
[ __ ] superhero that never happens
like it's so uncommon to have a game
that looks that scary where it seems
like you are costing spells of some kind
implying that you have some kind of
supernatural abilities like that's so
uncommon I think Resident Evil will
occasionally touch on that with like an
unlimited rocket launcher but for the
most part horror games don't give you
that much power so it's and I love
horror so it's so curious about it's
about reducing your power right right
taking you making you feel like you
don't stand a chance is such an easy way
to make things really tits
that's why as a tangent off of that have
you watched the Amazon series the boys
what how are you not you did watch
psycho I did well before we get into
that because that's also potentially I
think I think - oh should never we
should always just like star wars
usually reference it and they're never a
new film we've got time it's still
trending that's true we'll figure it out
I do recommend the boys
so I I really liked it and I but I liked
that it shows the grizzly side of the
realistic sort of yeah absolute mayhem
hot because it basically is a superhero
Horror Show that's also kind of a dark
comedy and and very pull bitly but yeah
that the idea that the idea that just
like the insane violence that superhero
powers would realistically exert on
especially unlike normal non superhero
people it's like a hardcore version of
Incredibles yeah
interestingly but also very cynical it's
it's very very cynical since it's all
about like how much they're trending on
social media and their value as a
superhero is based around clicks and
public engagement and all that kind of
like okay I was gonna say is it is it
very cynical in like a watchman kind of
way or is it just
I thought you say it's more cynical than
much much and it really hates people
it's a show that actively oh I don't
know if that's true because I mean it's
100% true like it's it's I love it it's
really good but like it definitely has a
very low estimation of like humanity and
who we are and what we can be like it's
definitely quite a downbeat show do you
don't think so do you see optimism in
the boys yeah really okay I have two
friends on the show
oh who your friends Jack Wade and Karl
Urban and they are they're both first of
all the biggest goofs in the world and
Karl always plays baddies always but to
me it's it's about other than Amer well
maybe he's the plate other like but by
and large by his own admission he's like
I always get called for baddies he's
like the character he played him born
and what else Star Trek right you got to
play bones I was a funny I'll tell you a
funny story about that later
he but I think it's the show at his ruse
is really about idolatry and hero
worship
and and so it's not less about our
humanity as much as it is about the
dangers of elevating anybody to a place
of idolatry
and saying we should hold these people
in high regard as I think it actually
elevates humanity rather than puts it
down but it shows that it's messy
everywhere like it shows because the
show simultaneously shows the danger of
holding people up as you say and that
idolatry but it also it shows both ends
of that for the heroes as well because
you see how some of them like it they
immediately get lost in that and they
they believe the [ __ ] about
themselves and then there's others that
are struggling by feeling like they are
not what they are held up to be and
there's like this internal kind of
almost almost like a split personality
of them of them trying to be be what is
sort of like the moneymaker but also be
what they feel is true to themselves and
especially as those get more and more
divergent I was I was funny cuz a friend
of mine wrote the music for the show so
I was hearing about it through him for a
while but I didn't know anything about
it and then it was like it had been out
for a while and I was just kind of
cruising this was a few months ago but I
was looking for something to watch and
so on hila and I put it on knowing very
little actually somehow I had it had
been out for a while and I'd heard you
know it was well-received and it was
like Amazon's biggest hit I think up
till up till now and it was like it had
gotten a lot of good mention but but
then yeah finally put it on and like
basically binge did in a day and a half
because I was this after the first
episode I was like holy hell this thing
is not [ __ ] around very busy from
like the first like oh my actually first
like 60 seconds of it it's like oh yeah
that's the best hold open in television
history
there's this new series there's more oh
yeah
I want to give a comic book series
called irredeemable it's not very long
but which is better
irredeemable incorruptible because I
have IVA take on this did you weird I
think I'm not gonna think you're
attainable the idea mobile starts better
and corruptible finishes better well
that the last episode of every Dima
whole is the best the last the very last
I think the opening is really [ __ ]
good too the opening is Fanta
red that serious it means a little bit
most people haven't and that's why I'm
like give that no idea what you guys are
talking like just the really basic
because I don't really want to tell you
anything else is what if Superman was
real and because of the way people
[ __ ] treat him because it's actually
not very kind he became a bad guy just
one day he goes right that's it
[ __ ] you like the girl he likes doesn't
like him when he's himself but likes the
superhero [ __ ] you
so it's just like he just kind of snaps
and plays everyone and it's very small
and it's it's it's really really good I
like I loved it that it is really just
flipping that and that seems like
vaguely similar to which one of the two
are you which one is that so
irredeemable is if the hero Falls then
the villain must rise so irredeemable is
the hero fallen and that's what a lotta
is talking about now yeah it's a
companion see likes but yeah so you have
super villain who turns good as well so
yeah and so eventually what happens is
they converge and it's they flip the
script on it and it's just like if who
who do you send to stop a superhero you
send a super villain and it's just like
let's go
Oh max damage oh it's so it's probably
pretty cheap to pick up now to like i
highly recommend it checking it out it's
like we had once i found oh yeah it's on
comiXology i think i think i just I
found it in him like I used to just go
to the comic book store once a week and
just pick out a cover that I thought
look cool and that was one of those
where I just picked it up and was like
yeah this is dope really similar but
even though it meanders and it doesn't
answer for like several issues
how long them no but the way that it
lands is is so good very good stuff
highly good we go very far away from the
PlayStation conference back to weird
ears the color alone I was like I don't
know man
like I missed I missed just like that
even the piano black of the ps2 or the
ps3 you know like I I missed I think
hoping it'll really seems like yeah I
did I did comment on hello that the the
the it does remind me of I I do
associate the that sort of design
aesthetic I get may be said it's not the
right word but maybe it's just purely
the white color but I said it does feel
Nintendo to me
yeah to say it was white boy console
yeah yeah I know we see they pulled
Owens it reminded me of Tom Cruise's
apartment in the movie oblivion I was
like this console would be would be in
that apartment and I'm down with that
I liked the I liked the ultra missus how
someone would design a future console if
he told them to do it in 2005 this is
exactly what they would like I'm looking
at blah I just I have a thing where
almost all new hardware I think looks
silly from the jump like I've got my PS
/ sitting in front of me right now
because I've been playing the lost of
his pot to you on it and it at first I
was like looks like a goddamn hamburger
but now I'm like it just takes a while
for you to get used to hardware because
it seems like something is every single
console exactly every every single one
except the Gamecube which from the jump
had a handle so therefore was
objectively the best everything else
it's just a mess but I I mean it is
really different so it looks like the
way for the record that it's it's it's
on the side is there's like a little
stand you can put on the bottom of it
so it has this like succulent and and
then it'll stay above it won't touch
anything kind of but there's there's
literally geniuses and one in particular
that is in charge of designing this
right like I'm there's nothing that is
going to be it's gonna be perfect or
you've left a mark Cerny right
he's gonna go like I don't care about
that you hold it this way because it's
its form follows function
for for sure yeah so I know that there's
a reason for everything one of the
biggest things obviously is optical
drive the fact that they're not everyone
thought is like this is the LAT the ps4
is give me the last bastion of hard
format you know and and discs yeah discs
will be gone I thought it was gonna be a
purely digital console well you can show
- what is an optical drive in one dozen
yes so there's playstation five and then
the playstation 5 digital edition oh
I'll have the digital edition so I I
just don't buy I have discs and
typically it's because people have like
here man you've worked in this game
here's the disc I'm like that's awesome
that's not what keeps sake and I and I
have my little library of games but
unless it's a unless it's a legacy game
I don't have it and typically I can buy
it about 50 like just sitting in a
bookcase over there and I have more in
Australia but I don't okay I actually
did really recently put a disc in but
that would be the most recently that I
have any year mostly they just sit there
and I have an attachment to discs I like
collecting stuff in general but I also
even though you even if you have a disc
you still don't technically own the
thing you just have a physical license
rather than a digital one I don't like
the idea of things being digitally tied
to an account in terms of ownership I
feel like it just was very shady well I
mean you know if you lose your access to
every single game you bought on Steam
like I just if but like how often does
that happen is that this is the way that
the entire industry works and anybody
like Austin I'm sure you with the
software libraries and the plugins and
everything that you have there is so
many layers of protection for that
happening and to the point where it
becomes a service it's an add-on suite
of services that you can get to make
sure that in the event that that happens
thank god you paid the $4.99 a year or
whatever to cover all of your license
that you should your
I transferred like there's some stuff
that I have on my computer that is
licensed only to this computer now
they're all licensed to a cloud so if I
change computers I can clearly or easily
move all of my licenses over and be able
to do that that's just the way the
industry needs to work right yeah and
there are examples you know like a like
with Netflix you know where you know
they they won't like it for whatever
reason a license on a title won't renew
and so if you're relying on Netflix -
what like let's say your favorite well I
think the office is actually a good
example like the office I think was the
most-watched show on Netflix like by far
it was just insane the number of people
that but there they kept saying you know
the license will expire and it's gonna
leave Netflix and and it did and it's
like so when you know if you well I
think it's gone now isn't it they've
certainly been saying it was gonna leave
science friends friends left and then
they went over to HBO max so much
switched it yeah friends that was the
whole thing is like they they go yeah
it's Seinfeld in fact maybe I'm thinking
of friends but the point is that that I
think you are thinking difference yeah
yeah yeah but yes so my error
notwithstanding the the point is that
the the lack of ability to kind of
control where you see a thing
easily compared with just it's on my
shelf I can see why that's I'm mostly
actually with Troy on this one I really
though is right I know he's correct my
new ringtone text tone Silent Hill PT is
such a good example of why it makes me
uneasy is that like I have my bass ps4
sitting down there and I panic quite
frequently about that console and
plug-in in once every six months just to
make sure it's still working because I'm
like they took Silent Hill PT away that
games gone make sure it's free and it's
a demo but it's still something and I'm
like I I would be mortified if I lost
this I probably would be one of those
people who would then buy $1,000 ps4 on
eBay just for the chance to have that
game
and you can actually transfer it between
consoles they really need to do that so
you can share it to your own consoles
I'm just gonna do that to every piece of
hardware I get that can take PT it's
going to have people yeah that is so
anomalous right that is that is just the
that's right that's why I ultimately
agree with you is I recognize that those
are hedge cases like Alan Wake on Steam
you know a number of years ago is
another example of Don noticing a trend
with Konami that's weird
they've been like a couple of things
that have just people have lost access
to you when they've bought them and
again you still don't own a game just
because you own a disc though you just
own the license in a physical form and
especially now but for practical
purposes you do own it I mean like what
are they gonna send send the business to
your to your house and you like we're
gonna need that back we first give me
the lam I think that the lamp no the
idle sorry Adam I'll throw you the weep
I went I went Indiana Jones into Aladdin
for some weird reason I really did to
your point Troy like I will probably get
frankly will like if I'm buying it like
I will we will probably get review units
but I would I think I would buy the
digital version and I'm very interested
to see it gives you a sense of where we
are globally because it's so easy to
forget that other people really don't
have good internet connections I would
be working from home the phone house and
inside gaming right now in Australia if
I could I so desperately wish I could
but nobody in my family has good enough
internet for me to download a video game
in less than three days like I cannot do
it different reasons different so I
think we'll get a real good
understanding of where we're at globally
based on which one sells more and I'm
really interested to see those numbers
if I would love to know the demographics
on like by and large people who own
consoles if they are like I know Sean
that's available jacksepticeye you know
it started off a cabin in the woods you
know teefin bit of western Ireland you
know so I mean there's clearly people
out there that are kind of off the grid
and this is what they do so I I
understand it's disenfranchising for a
lot of people
like yo man I don't I'm having a very
you know a narrow margin of a user base
like I just upgraded my internet to a
thousand Meg I've got one gig down thank
you that's it's in it's hot man I I like
uploading and downloading videos and
stuff that I've been doing or making
sure that I can have super high res
bandwidth for for recording especially
from home has been necessary but that's
because I live in LA if I was in
somewhere else was like we got that AOL
what comes up again did you got mail you
know exactly how my family sounds that's
exactly there's a very strange spot on
Queensland accent was 22 down and that
was the fastest of all of them and I
called all of them I was like I wish I
could work from home there's nothing
stopping me I'd have to be on an
American timezone but I don't care I
could be at home and that would be the
best but I would have to quit my job and
lose all my money so I but that's not
that's not like I mean what about like
there on the sticks that's right my
family is not out in the sticks and
that's the thing they're in a major city
the third largest city in the [ __ ]
country it's just a stray Lina there's
only four cities though we only have
[Laughter]
that that seems to be pervasively true
about all of Australia even Sydney it's
like I uploaded a video to it was it was
a halo video the Master Chief collection
originally I remember this I was in a
hotel in Melbourne and the video had
finished uploading before I had managed
to fill out the title and the tags and I
was like does that mean it just goes
live what happens because they're all
parts of Melbourne where it's really
well supported which is actually why the
bulk of the game that I've seen in
Australia is in melton is it Melbourne I
would imagine honestly that either the
tech sector or hotels you're gonna find
the fastest internet as well because by
and large it's all the out-of-towners
used to fast internet that what is slow
internet no I remember
I was collaborating with tripod on
something and I kept sending them WAV
files and they were like we don't want
to be jerks but can you send mp3s
because it just takes so much longer to
download on our damned Ozzy Internet and
I was like really because I've been to
Sandy Sydney and Adelaide and Brisbane
and Melbourne and all all seemed like
completely modern cities by every
measure that you could to analyze that
and they were like yet but just the
infrastructure underneath it for the
internet it's very old yeah and the
current government is not interested in
replacing it the most recent quote that
I heard from a politician was we just
don't understand why we need it because
they don't recognize the business now
it's ridiculous it really it really
sucks I hope they [ __ ] fix it but we
only have 8 minutes left so I won't make
us talk about my Australian internet was
for the rest of it I just want to do
what's most important sorry well I don't
this is part of ideas please bike more
far more important when holy soul
observing okay I'll no worries um so my
question Archie for you guys was it's
much more it was much more concise right
there was and the intros were very short
it was much more like a direct in terms
of like yeah there was no spreadsheets
there was there was the celebratory kind
of video at the start of the Troy videos
we've discussed the kind of highlight
reel but like it seems odd to me that
they it was a much shorter conference
than we used to I'm just interested what
you guys thought I wonder if that's part
of what prevented the kind of excitement
and walk I told it a little bit was just
there wasn't even feel like such a big
event it was very it was very concise
and I want to say any claims which was
what we always want I fit in between
Austin and Troy on my read of it and
that I was I was maybe more excited than
it seems like Troy was less excited than
Austin I was like very meddling on it I
like the pacing of it a whole lot it was
a this is such a like a
minor complaint but I hated that they
just kept transitioning between things
with the logo when in the room they've
had us just snap between trailers before
even when we were there in person
they've had a go trailer trailer trailer
trailer whereas they kept pulling up
that that PlayStation logo every time I
think they're trying to think about a
marketing is going we have to instill
this into people it's no longer Sony
interactive entertainment now it's
PlayStation Studios like we were they're
trying to they're launching a console
they're also rebranding get the I get
the the literal like you mean the ident
you mean like graphic yes I mean the
graphics like it would show up with the
like the triangle and the the cross your
samba loading screen wait a minute
you're saying mixed signals no loading
screens except for when we talk about it
they are loading screens yeah no I I
think it was stilt over two hours though
no really it felt false I think it
wasn't two hours yeah I think I really
do because I know that I had a podcast
scheduled immediately like there with
more games than usual I think and
definitely more indie games which was
cool but like there was very little
fellows very lean other than as you say
those really long I guess
well it's worth I liked that for I like
I like the it sometimes those things
should the traditional format to
sometimes feel very indulgent and like
now they've got a whole weekend and a
stadium full of people to kind of cater
to so it's it makes sense that it would
be more indulgent it's actually more
appropriate to that context but for me
in the context of everybody's watching
this on youtube I think sort of getting
to the point and showing some top level
kind of highlights and some major
trailers and then being like and we're
out I felt about that felt about right
for me so I didn't think it was - I
liked the relative narrative for me it
was just always an interesting shift and
I wonder I keep asking myself with all
of this stuff like whether we're gonna
go back like whether like whether we
will have the good question maybe not in
our e3 where
McGhee that comes out of the stage Xbox
I keep doing it and when a Microsoft
theater like I don't think Xbox has
reason to stop I don't think PlayStation
will do it again
I think PlayStation wants to do their
own there they're so focused on
community they were already building PSX
up they were already pulling out of e3
they were already stopping to do you
know any other trade shows before
besides I think that those shows are
gonna be more about developer than
publisher or definitely Hardware because
there's just not much of a need for him
let's put the developer forward or even
put the publisher forward put your
Activision's and your Ubisoft's forward
and let them showcase their games but as
far as like hardware I don't think they
need to be there I don't think the
PlayStation needs to be there it's
different when you have so many first
party studios but I think that there's
probably gonna be I don't know trade
shows come back man
III has been trying to to kind of keep
up and change when it when it when it
stopped being a trade show and started
being a public show yeah I feel like
that got away from what III was I know
we talked about this before Mike where
you're like this is still where I do a
majority of business in Austin the same
way but I feel like those things will
transition over to GDC and I don't ever
want to see something like GDC become
like I don't want to come see cosplayers
of GDC because that's such an important
for students for example such an
important in person networking event
that that one going digital I feel like
is a huge loss I really like I'm already
feeling like I'm already feeling and
then both in terms of like there's you
know buddies in the industry - I see
every event camp friend like ya know I
was like what Ramy does Remi that like
he's been so instrumental and
influential as as far as getting like
game makers especially from the Middle
East who would never have the
opportunity like he's met some like says
yeah I get to get him to GDC so I don't
work out those meetings it's it's I feel
like I've said it before on the show but
like I think the I think players
underestimate how
that's actually the point of these
events to some extent like you know
people like me who need to I mean I need
to go out every two or three years and
sell someone on letting me make a game
you know I'm like there's a business
there and it's it's we're doing fine to
be clear but like it's definitely harder
it's harder to get stuff in front of I
feel like close conversation three five
twenty meetings in three days just
doesn't happen you can't get previews
efficiently without III I know that like
from the amount of ones I've done on
discord two of which I scrapped entirely
because the footage was so unwatchable
when they were streaming that's games
though my average in-person they don't
know my four years ago I guess at GDC
was when I get a message from a friend
who said hey I got a buddy who's sitting
at the W Hotel bar and you should go
meet him he's there right now and I went
over there and that was Jack at Ridge
and literally the only reason I ended up
scoring Erica was because I went and met
a random stranger at a bar during GDC
and something like that happens at
almost every GDC there's another game I
get to announce that I'm in soon that
was Austin III they had a meeting with
me at e3 that probably wouldn't have
happened otherwise I'm not gonna email
me and ask me to do this stuff you know
and what I love is it's also it's not
necessarily the behind closed doors it's
it's was just in the food court people
were coming up asking us for photos so
weird that's that's what I miss is that
I do miss the opportunity to like you
said Austin camp friends and and more
than anything more than the games that
are announced to me that the reason why
I like these press conferences the
reason why I like these events is that
it reminds us that it's it's such a
community of people it's and it is a
partnership between the player and the
publishers and the people that are
making the games that at the core of
what all of this is that's what's most
important so we could talk about the
ray-tracing we could talk about the
intricacies of sorry about the
ray-tracing but the we stand like it's
all about it's all about the people that
that
have made that hardware have made that
title that are putting the controller in
the hands of the players that that is
what to me this is all about and that's
something that no matter how it looks
whether it's online or in person that's
the thing that's always at the root of
this and that's what I'll always be
excited about it is hard sometimes to
remember how friendly and passionate and
and excited the games community can be
when you're not getting to see those
people in person and it's something that
I've always found important for my
career I've been walking on the internet
or I've had a larger than average
following on the internet for I think 10
years now and that can be really awful
until you're in person and then people
are the best and you get to talk to
people who like the same stuff as you
add a pax about whatever game whatever
indie game they play that they were
excited about and that is just you can't
do that on the Internet and it's so nice
and it does feel like a really big loss
because our industry is really [ __ ]
cool and impressive and full of so many
creative people and yeah losing the
ability to to just like enthuse about
that in person is a thing that like
where I shouldn't clink for example this
is a thing that I keep wanting to talk
to people about but what forum do I have
to do that like if I were my words the
JW yes this podcast that would be the
one that I would be like but look at
what that game was doing if I tweet that
people like oh you mean and then I have
to just explain it and it's just not as
fun so yes it does feel like a loss but
for the conference in general I think I
did really enjoy it to fully answer your
question Mike the one thing that I think
probably prevented my hype is that they
want that many reveals that I was super
excited about I knew about any like big
kind of Shenmue style oh my god they
lost Guardian even Final Fantasy I mean
Demon Souls Remos unfortunately some of
these were like basically leak so
horizon we knew about Demon Souls didn't
way I felt like we knew that we weren't
supposed to go you did yes yes we did I
forget what the name is but horizon zero
dawn - we knew about I didn't know about
Resident Evil 8 that one I had no idea I
was hoping for something Silent Hill
related as unlikely as that seems
yeah it was a lot of names that we'd
already seen so for me that the bomber
was not getting huge new titles
spider-man's really the only one that
like really shocked there is always that
slow speed up isn't there the star the
console generation there's definitely
like I feel like the big things the
games we're gonna love and remember are
the ones we're gonna hear about yes fool
was kind of an outlier ps4 had some
really good games you usually get from a
launch sites also sure you're you're
discounting the fact that in the montage
at the end the single shot they showed
from the pathless was a specific
particular archery animation that had
not been revealed before so I'm a little
insulted
lack of hype over the archery animation
so yeah there was my games are also
secret they weren't in it I think it
might have been like Nico or something
that looked very studio ghibli the one
that had like they literally look like
the Ghibli sit sprites from spirited
away Oh another one you mean yeah it was
kind of like um yeah yeah a little bit
Pikmin II but also like I would guess
that it's a Metroidvania at that one I
was like that game looks incredible
still very indie looking which like not
to discount that I guess I just want to
know what the first party studios are
working on in general I mean we do know
of as far as guerrilla and some niak
econsent
which like just always want to say Sony
buying insomniac people kept when that
announcement came out kept
congratulating insomniac and I was like
it congratulate Sony like that is such a
good studio with so many talented to
their writing stuff is full of some of
the coolest women I've ever [ __ ] met
in my life I love them they're so cool
and it's just yeah and Sony I just
[ __ ] even made really good all right
let's do the top like even the bosses of
insomniac rule yeah just a great studio
[ __ ] acquiring insomniac
all the way it's like so lucky to be
able to do that so definitely stuff to
be excited about I'm glad we got to see
what it looked like I want to know how
much it costs and I would like to see
more games but you are right my question
still isn't it like that's a question
probably just be yeah see what happens
we'll buy each other a pizza I'm in a
guess I was I was gonna say good I know
them now I'm girl what are the what is
the question on how much it's going to
cost and we will buy food and have it
delivered to someone's house along you
got you got 450 I guess for 3449 the the
digital-only version is okay it's gonna
be more appealing so I think what
they're gonna do is they're gonna go 399
for the digital they're gonna go $4.99
for the optical okay so yeah $4.99 is
your doing because I said 500 so you're
really I said 550 for optical Troy you
said 499 have to keep you to that and
Austin it's 109
yeah keep it to me okay I know Scott how
you sprayed your closest without going
over they could do 501 you know and then
it's like Austin wins I would be in that
in five Oh first because it's a Star
Wars Edition and that's what it is right
it's that that's what now we understand
why white white and black would be good
save this document and I remind myself
to look at it what would be hilarious as
if they did a five hundred and first
edition that's pure white but then
there's just a scorch mark somewhere
right
right before I really do have to go I
don't think that canceling what is it is
it I want to say 20 23 23 I don't think
they canceled it and I don't think
they're going to I think that's gonna
because that oh people just is really
couldn't yeah they're opening the parks
very bad objects they're like we're
still doing the show that seems insane
it's in August they're opening the parks
and they're gonna have a conference is
gonna be like the test of the conference
where everyone's wearing masks maybe
everyone comes out with a Disney themed
mask this microphone [ __ ] god damn
they're gonna hand out stormtrooper
helmets as they're as wise I feel like
his mask he has this like it's got
lights in it it's got wiring in it it's
like a cyberpunk fabulous boy all right
thank you for joining us everyone this
week I am leaving links in the
description for this show probably
indefinitely for places that we would
love to see you guys donate to instead
of supporting the show financially if
that's the thing that you are able to do
thank you to everyone who donated last
week I ended up submitting the amount
that we raised for the Minnesota freedom
fund campaign yesterday and it totaled
$65,000 which is amazing so thank you
guys so much for all of your support we
appreciate it I thought so absolutely
with everyone out there protesting and
fighting the good fight and doing what
we can
so thank you for listening to the show
thank you for supporting us and thank
you for letting us talk about video
games in your ears this was nice at any
point in time we'll see you guys next
week what we're waving